[Music]
Hello to you some TV friends and family.
Welcome to I'd like to know our Bible
question and answer program here at
Secrets Unsealed. We are so pleased that
you have joined us this afternoon and we
pray that you will be blessed through
your sitting with us. My name is CA
Murray and I'm in the presence of Pastor
David Salazar and Pastor Steven Boore.
We're here to answer your questions from
the word of God. You send in the
questions, we give you the answer from
the word of God. That's how this works.
If you would like to get in on the fun,
we encourage you to do so by sending
your questions to
tvsumtv. That's summ as in
marytv.org. That is
tvsumtv.org. and we will get to your
questions just as quickly as we possibly
can. Pastor Boore, would you please uh
ask the Lord's blessing upon this
particular city? Certainly, Father in
heaven, as we u undertake the task of u
answering these questions, we realize
that our knowledge and wisdom is very
limited. But you are omnisient and you
have all of the answers to all of the
questions, no matter how complex they
are. Amen. And so we come before your
throne and we plead for your presence
through the ministry of the Holy Spirit.
Give us clarity of
thought and give those who are watching
this program tenderness of heart as well
as ours so that we might not only
understand the answers but also apply
them to our daily lives. Amen. This we
pray in the name the powerful name of
Jesus. Amen. Amen. And amen. Our first
question comes to us from Samuel who is
uh writing to us from Brazil and thank
you for writing to us Samuel. Pastor
Boore would you read this question for
us please? Uh yes this is the the
question. Hello blessings for you. My
name is Samuel always it is a privilege
to watch the program here in Brazil.
Praise the Lord that we have people in
Brazil watching the programming. My
question is this. Ellen White says in
various statements that there is no
excuse for sin. None can be forced to
sin, that sin is not a necessity, that
Satan cannot compel anyone to sin. Now
the Bible says that all have sinned and
that if we say we have not sinned, we
deceive ourselves and that it does not
exist a ma or a person does not exist on
earth that sinnth not. The universality
of sin and then in parentheses he puts
uh the fact that all humans that lived
sinned. So the universality of sin
proves that it is inevitable. It's a
question. Is it inevitable for a person
who is born in this world to sin? That
is transgress the law in word, thought,
or deed. Even just one time, let me let
me be more clear. A person that is born
in this world is destined to sin for the
purpose that Romans 3:23 could have
sense. Can we understand Romans 3:23
also as a verse that declares that all
will sin? It does not matter what
happens if you are born from Christian
parents or not. That person will sin
anyway. That person will sin in some
moment. If that is so, then why does
Ellen White say that there is no excuse
for sin? Is she talking about Christians
only? Uh in parenthesis, there is no
necessity for sin in the Christian and
not of the whole world. And if that is
so, how can God judge and bring
condemnation to a person if sin is in
ineedible uh inevitable even for one
time?
If I cannot avoid sin even for one time,
how can God be just in judging
people? So basically the gist of it
is we're going to sin, right?
And Ellen White, what does Ellen White
mean when she says that we need not sin?
We don't have to sin. Well, I think that
the the premise that um Samuel is taking
from it's it's a little bit um perhaps
incorrect in a sense. We have to
remember
that
the the origin of
sin is cannot be attributed to God,
cannot be blamed in the Lord. It had had
no reason to exist. There was
no you
know experience for it to come into into
existence. Lucifer changed his heart cho
choose to follow his his pride and his
selfishness and became you know he
became a the person who started all sin.
Now when we come to the earth when we
were you know as as human beings when we
enter into the separation of God when we
believed a lie and speaking of or Adam
and Eve when they believed Satan Lucifer
and the serpent and they took of the
fruit of the tree of good and evil we
became
uh under the spell of the enemy. We
became under the curse of sin. We as an
as a as a as a race are now under
bondage to sin. So that means that when
you are born, you have propensity, you
have the tendency, the natural heart is
going to pull you into the sin. You have
that pull naturally in it. So uh this is
why the Bible is clearly says that all
have sinned. In other words, every human
being is born in emnity in separation
from God. And because of that, that is
why you are naturally going to go into
the path of sin. So you need the
salvation or the aid from an external
source which is Christ. This is why the
apostle John in 1 John 3 and verse 6 he
mentions something very
important. It says whoever abides in him
does not sin. So when you are abiding in
Christ then there is no then this
experience of sin is no longer a
necessity. sin no longer has a reason to
exist. You can have the victory in
Christ because you are abiding in
Christ. Christ has come into your life.
You accepted his his influence, his
power, his will in your life. And
therefore, you're a new creature. You
are born again. You can have that
experience, but without that experience
of being born into again and be born
into Christ, you will naturally sin. And
this is why the necessity of of of
salvation that we all have.
So we're all born with a bent human
nature towards sin. Right? Ellen White
calls it a propensity. Correct? We all
have the propensity to sin. But she also
says that none need retain any sinful
pro propensity. So in other words, uh
you know, people say, well uh we have a
a sinful nature and the sinful nature is
going to sin. Mhm. It's inevitable. And
therefore, we're going to be sinning
until Jesus comes in the clouds of
heaven. Yeah. Uh to take away our sinful
nature and to give us a sinless nature.
Uh but those who pass through the time
of trouble are not going to sin. No.
There's no intercessor for sin during
the time of trouble. Mhm. Now, were they
sinners in their lives? Yeah, they were
sinners. But through the power of the
Holy Spirit were they able to overcome
sin even to the point during the time of
trouble of living without sinning in
action in thought and feelings etc.
where they reached the point where they
say though he slay me yet will I trust
in him like like Job said. Um so uh all
of us at some point have allowed our
sinful nature to express itself in sin.
Mhm. But that doesn't mean that we have
to stay that way. You know that text
that says, "I can do most things through
Christ who strengthens me." Right? That
test doesn't exist. He says, "I can do
all things." But but doesn't it say I
can do all things except overcome sin
through Christ who strengthens me. That
is exactly another mistake. It says I
can do all things through Christ who
strengthens me. Mhm. So, uh, some people
say, well, it's legalism to say that
God's people are going to totally
overcome sin before the second coming.
It's only legalism if you think that
you're doing it yourself. Exactly. You
depend on and that you're doing it to
earn salvation. Precisely. Then it's
legalism. But if you do it because you
love Jesus, like Daniel for example,
when he was going to be thrown into the
lion's den, why was he willing to be
eaten by the lions? Because he loved the
Lord. That's right. And why did the
three young men who were thrown into the
fiery furnace, why did they say, "We
would rather die than worship your
image, why did they say that? Was it
because, oh, you know, we better we
better uh, you know, go along. That way
the fire won't burn us." No, they're
actually saying we love the Lord and
faithfulness to the Lord is more
important than our own lives. That's
right. That's what's going to happen
during the time of trouble. Mhm. People
will live without sin because they love
the Lord. Amen. And they do it through
the power of the Holy Spirit. Yeah. Not
their own power. Because if they
depended on their sinful nature, they
would sin. But the sinful nature will be
totally under the control of the Holy
Spirit. Amen. And amen. This is why you
know that verse in in John as you
mentioned pastor, you know, the key
thing is abiding in Christ. You depend
on the Lord. In verse 7 through9, I'm
going to read so that kind of give the
context of what we're mentioning. He
says, "Little children, let no one
deceive you. He who practices
righteousness is righteous just as he is
righteous." In other words, because you
abide in Christ, you are able to have
the works of righteousness. Amen. Who he
who sins is of the devil. For the devil
has sinned from the beginning. For this
purpose, the son of God was manifested
that he might destroy the works of the
devil. Whoever has been born of God does
not sin for his seed remains in him and
he cannot sin because he has been born
of God. So again, the key for for to
have a v victory to be have to have that
strength to overcome is as long as you
depend on the Lord as you're born in the
Lord and you remain in him. That is the
only way people will have victory over
sin and those that are in the time will
go through the time of trouble because
they have hidden their lives in Christ
and are dependent on the Lord 100%. You
know that word abide. That word abide.
Yeah. Reminded me of the parable of the
vine and the branches. Correct. Where in
John 15 Jesus says, "I am the vine, you
are the branches." I didn't mean he who
abides in me and I in him bears much
fruit which is the fruit of the spirit.
Right? Against which there is no law
according to the apostle Paul. Uh then
he says, "For without me you can do
nothing." So those who go through the
time of trouble, they're not depending
on themselves. They're connected with
Jesus. Amen. If anyone does not abide in
me, he is cast out as a branch and is
withered and they gather them and throw
them into the fire and they are burned.
That's what's going to happen with the
wicked who don't abide in in Christ. If
you abide in me and my words abide in
you, you shall ask what you desire and
it shall be done for you. By this my
father is glorified that ye bear much
fruit so you will be my disciples. Amen.
Powerful passage. I was uh had the
same chapter here. John 15 is the the
abiding chapter. John comes back to this
idea over and over again. He touches it,
then he alludes to it, then he touches
it again. You read um 1 John 3:6. Well,
three verses later he says again,
"Whoever is born of God does not sin."
three times in in this this series of
books, he says, "If you're born of God,
you do not sin." But then he throws you
a little curve because in in John 2:1,
he says, "And if we sin, we have an
advocate with the father." So, it almost
sounds like he's talking out of both
sides of his mouth. But he's not. He's
he's he's following through on his
thesis that um once you are aware of
sin, you you you you surrender it. You
get it. He who does not He who does not
practice sin, you know, you don't lay
down in sin, you don't wallow in sin,
you don't you don't uh just fall down in
sin. Uh but if you make a mistake if
something happens, you've got an
advocate with the father. Now to to tie
in what you just said, but there is
coming a time because of our preferences
to follow the Lord because we are
abiding in the Lord. It is
not untoward for God to seal us in that
decision. In other words, I want Jesus.
I've followed Jesus. I've laid down my
life for Jesus. I've sacrificed for
Christ. I've I've I've called upon his
goodness and his grace to come in and
take control of my life. I want the
Lord. If the Lord says, "Let him who is
just be just still." That is not
something we did not ask for, that we
did not work for, that we did not
request. So, there's coming a time when
we will live without an intercessor and
sin will not have power over us. It's
about It's not about avoidance. It's
about overcoming. Amen. And if we if we
abide, we will overcome. Amen. Amen.
Amen. Praise the Lord. Yeah. Good
question. Great question coming from
Brazil. We're happy that um you spend a
little time in South America. Uh I have
not gotten past Panama yet. You are from
South America. I've not gotten past the
ismas, but you guys have spent time in
South America. I'm going to be in Brazil
the middle of April. Praise the Lord.
Lord willing. Yeah. Praise the Lord. The
great big conference that they're having
down there. Amen. Amen. is a few days.
If I if I spoke Portuguese or Spanish
decently, I would I would carry a
suitcase. No follow Portuguese.
All right, our next one is 43. Pastor
David. Yes. All right. Would you read
that question for us? Absolutely. It
says here, "Hello, I I would like to
know, is it necessary that I do personal
devotion
daily? Can I do it some days? And what
is the best content? How long should it
be? and what time is needed. Thank you
so much pastor bore and team. So this is
an individual you know that wants to
know if it's necessary to have personal
devotion and if so is it daily important
or just how many days can he do it a
couple of days and what is the best
content how long it should be and what
time is needed. First let's let's deal
with the daily question. It depends how
strong a Christian you want to be. If
you want to run a race and you lay on
the couch and eat potato chips and
cookies and cake and then decide you're
going to go out and do a marathon, well,
guess what? You're not going to be able
to do it. If you want to decide you want
to fight against your own inherent
nature to serve the Lord and you don't
put yourself in connection with the
Lord, the question we just we just dealt
with, you don't abide in the Lord. Mh.
When you are challenged, you're going to
fail just like you would if you were
trying to run a race and never practice.
So, should you do it daily? My answer is
yes.
The Lord the Lord Christ he was um the
prophet says that he daily would spend
time in prayer with the Lord in with his
father. He he said himself, you know, he
would do the works of the father and
everything that the father would say to
him, he would do. He did not speak of
himself. So every day the lord had to
ask the father had that communion with
father and if Jesus our savior had to
have communion with his father on a
daily basis. I don't think we have a you
know any other u argument to say against
that we need to have a daily communion
with god. It's just what is required to
be connected to the source of all
wisdom, all truth. How many people say
I'm going to eat Monday, Wednesday, and
Friday?
Maybe some months. I'm only I'm only
going to eat off and on, you know.
And but that's not life. And the
devotional life is food. Yeah. Uh let me
read this statement from the desire of
ages. A very well-known statement. Uh
Ellen White wrote this is uh let me see
it's on page I'll tell you in a
minute.
Uh it's on page 83 of Desire of Rages.
This is what she wrote. It would be well
for us to spend a thoughtful hour each
day. Mhm. Because the question also t
asks about the the frequency,
right? Yes. Uh and what is and what is
the best content. Yeah. So here this one
is on the content and also on the the
time frame. It would be well for us to
spend a thoughtful hour each day
in contemplation of the life of Christ.
We should take it point by point and let
the imagination grasp each
scene especially the closing ones. Mhm.
As we thus dwell upon this great his
great sacrifice for us, our confidence
in him will be more constant, our love
will be quickened and we shall be more
deeply imbued with his spirit. If we
would be saved at last, we must learn
the lesson of penitence and humiliation
at the foot of the cross. Amen. So she
says a thoughtful hour every day
especially of the closing scenes of
Christ's life which means uh Gethsemane
the cross maybe even before his trial
before Pilate uh the upper room uh you
know the closing scenes of his life have
power to transform our lives.
Amen. I I think that you know this verse
that came to my mind just to re
reinforce this concept in Luke
9:23 Jesus said then he said to them all
if anyone desires to come after me let
him deny himself and take up his cross
daily and follow me. Amen. So you know
this is the only way the Lord says for
me to for you to follow me is that you
have to come daily take the portion that
I give you every day. But if you don't
go to the Lord every day for that
portion, for the cross that he wants you
to continue to to to his yoke to be on
you, then you won't be able to have
really that experience of following him
and to truly be with him. It's just not
possible.
The truth is the mana fell every day.
Every day. And people were supposed to
go pick it up six days, but on the sixth
day twice as much so that they would
have for the seventh day. So they were
supposed to eat every day. Yeah. Yeah.
And the mana of course represents Christ
as manifested in the word. So that
teaches us that we are to feed on the
word of God every day. I'm working on a
sermon uh I don't know if it's just
going to be a whole sermon or an
anecdote in a sermon. Uh about if they
didn't get the mana early in the
morning, it melted. Yeah. Bible says,
you know, it didn't stay here. Yeah.
It's in the Bible. It didn't stay there
all day. You know, you have to get it
early. Get out and get it while the
getting is good because if you delay it,
it was going to melt. So, not only is it
important for us to get it every day,
but to get it make it an early part of
your day, right? Because once you get up
and get into doing things and showering
and dressing and going to work and I
I'll I'll do it a little bit later.
Well, you come there, the man has
melted, man. You got too many things
going on in your life. So, get it early
uh so that you can be fortified for the
day each and every day. Well, you know
what Jesus said? He said, uh, give us
this week our weekly bread.
our daily bread. Obviously, I'm being
facitious as I can
be. Jesus said, "What?" He said, "Give
us this day our daily bread. Our daily
bread." So, we So, so what would happen
if he said, "Well, you know, I'm going
to go a week without devotionals." You
know, if you continued with that, you'd
get sick and eventually you would die.
Yeah. That's why you have so many dead
Christians is because they're not
feeding their soul. Yes. And maybe
they're feeding their bodies too much
and not their soul enough. Yeah. And in
regards to the question of what is the
best content? Well, you know, you can't
go wrong with the word of God. Amen. You
know, there's so much to read to study,
but I think that uh you know, I think
you can start with things that are very
simple and easy to understand like the
Gospels or Proverbs or Psalms. I think
that, you know, it really needs
according to your need. But I think if
you pray to the Lord, if you seek the
Lord's wisdom, the Bible speaks that the
Holy Spirit is the one that teaches all
things and he'll bring to your memory or
to your or direct you to the portions of
the scripture that you need to study and
and go over. So I think it's it's
important to make that uh you know
decision, a personal decision. Lord help
me to understand your scripture and uh
just study the word of God, open the
word of God with a desire to learn. And
I think starting with Genesis is very
easy because Genesis is just a bunch of
stories stories. It's narrative. I love
Genesis. It's very easy to read, right?
And so is Exodus. Yeah. Now, when you
get to Leviticus and uh you know into
Numbers, then things become more
complicated. But uh you if you bear with
the text, Yeah. you're going to gain a
tremendous blessing and you're going to
learn and it's going to feed your soul.
Absolutely. Yeah. And as far as what
time is needed, as much as you want to
allocate, I think that like you well
mentioned said pastor, you know, if you
have to start early, maybe before the
day gets busy, spend time, you know,
dedicating to the scriptures, start
maybe, you know, with what's practical
to you, but try to always aim for more
with the word of God and not less. Some
people, you know, I've heard somebody
says, "I only have five minutes to pray
and go through my devotion." That
doesn't work. But I remember hearing
from somebody else that he would um
because he had to drive an hour for
work, he would uh pray uh and then as
he's driving, he would put the portion
of the scripture he wanted to hear as
he's driving. So he would be studying,
you know. So you have to find a way that
works best. But don't don't don't be
cheap on the Lord on this time with the
Lord. You know, you know, Mark 135 has
several elements about the devotional
life talking about Jesus, our example.
Now in the morning, having risen a long
while before daylight before the kids
get up and there's noise in the house
and this and that. Yeah. He went out and
departed to a solitary place
and there he prayed. Amen. So the
devotional life is best early in the
morning in a solitary place where you
can hear God's voice and where you can
meditate on him. Amen. In truth, you're
going to have to make time for the Lord.
You can not just take, you got to you
got to carve out time for the Lord.
Amen. Change your schedule to
accommodate God. It will be worth it.
Again, God bless you. We'll see you
again soon. And uh keep on praying, keep
on reading, keep on studying, keep on
growing in Jesus name. Amen. Bye-bye.
[Music]